imagine having a power to create a
dynamic website effortlessly manage
content and reach your target audience
with just a few clicks sounds too good
to be true right well not anymore today
we will explore an all-in-one tool
WordPress the Ultimate Game Changer in
the realm of website development and
content management
WordPress has become a go-to platform
for building stunning websites powering
over 40 percent of the entire internet
from blocks to e-commerce stores is the
ultimate tool that empowers their online
presence with ease it's a versatile and
a user-friendly platform that empowers
you to craft stunning websites without
encoding knowledge and today we are
going to list out the best WordPress
plugins of 2023 to transform your
websites but wait there's more if you
have ever dreamed of becoming a digital
marketing Maestro we have an exclusive
opportunity to blow your mind
introducing simply runs post digit
program in digital marketing that will
transform you into a master of digital
Ram
this comprehensive program designed by
industry expert provides you with
in-depth knowledge and practical skills
to excel in the fast-paced world of
digital marketing from SEO social media
marketing to content creation and
analytics this program covers all the
essential aspects of needed to conquer
the digital landscape which simply on
post treasure program in digital
marketing you will gain hands-on
experience with industry standard tools
work on real world projects and receive
personalized mentorship to guide you
every step of the way so if you are
ready to Unleash Your Potential and take
your digital marketing skills to the
next level then enroll in our
postgraduate program digital marketing
and become a game changer in the world
of online marketing you can find the
course Link in the description box below
but don't just believe us listen to what
our Learners have to say about our
courses
during my graduation we were taught
traditional advertising but the industry
demanded digital skills so finding a job
in the digital marketing domain was a
challenge for me I thought a
certification in digital marketing would
help me get a job and it did after the
course I was hired by pantalo as a
digital media specialist with a 20
salary hike and now I'm finally doing
what I like
hey I'm Isaiah Moore I live in Arizona
and the United States I did my
graduation in 2020 in strategic
Communications from Northern Arizona
University in 2020 I joined Nova Home
Loans as a trailing documents
coordinator and worked there for almost
a year in fact I worked at various
places as a student but after graduation
I couldn't find a job in my field of
study or anything that aligned with my
interests I gave tens of interviews but
without any luck the reason
I lacked practical skills on top of that
I had no certification in digital
marketing in particular
so last year I decided to upskill myself
with a professional certificate program
in digital marketing offered by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University I think it was a very good
decision I really liked the curriculum
it helped me enhance my Knowledge and
Skills last year itself after the course
I was hired by pantalope as a digital
media specialist with a 20 salary height
and this year I was promoted to digital
marketing account making
I finally found my footing in the
digital marketing domain and I think the
certification had a huge role to play
the certification helped me pursue my
desired career path I can use my skills
and experience to become a freelance
digital marketer one day upskilling has
helped me turn my dream into a reality
so without any further Ado let's check
out what we have in store for you for
this video
let's start with
WordPress
we will explore on precisely who uses it
finally we will dive deep into the top
10 WordPress plugins of tutorial 23. at
last we will wrap up this session with
some pros and cons of Wordpress so let's
get started with what is WordPress
WordPress is a popular content
management system that allows you to
create and manage websites with ease it
is flexible user friendly and Powers a
significant portion of the internet
WordPress provides a range of
customizable themes plugins and features
that makes it suitable for various
purposes from personal blogs to
e-commerce website but who uses it
WordPress is trusted and used by
numerous companies both large and small
across various Industries some notable
examples include the likes of New York
Times Sony Music Disney CNN and
Mercedes-Benz its versatility and
scalability makes it a Top Choice for
businesses and individuals alike now
let's get to the exciting part of
Wordpress plugins these handy tools
extend the functionality of your website
with over 58 000 plugins available in
the WordPress plugin directory you have
an incredible array of options to
enhance your website's features and
performance so here are 10 popular
WordPress plugins that can enhance your
functionality and features of your
website first up we have closed SEO
used SEO is a comprehensive plugin that
helps improve the search engine
optimization of the WordPress plugin it
provides range of features such as XML
sitemap
content analysis readability checks meta
tag customization and social media
integration yoast SEO helps you optimize
your content for better visibility in
search engine results leading to an
increased organic traffic next up we
have woocommerce it is a popular
e-commerce plugin that transforms your
WordPress websites into a full-fledged
online store it offers a user-friendly
interface for managing products
inventory orders and shipping with
woocommerce you can customize the
appearance of your store choose from
various payment gateways and exchange
functionality through add-ons and
extensions then we have jetpack jetpack
is an all-in-one plugin developed by
automatic the same company behind
wordpress.com it offers a wide range of
features to enhance your website
including performance optimization tools
social features traffic analytics social
sharing functionality content
configuration tools and more chat pack
simplifies the management of various
aspects of your website by consolidating
multiple functionalities into a single
plugin next up we have a Kismet a Kismet
is a plugin is specifically designed to
combat comment and content form spam it
filters incoming comments and forms
submissions by analyzing them against a
vast database of known spam patterns a
Kismet automatically detects and filters
of spam ensuring that only legitimate
comments and messages appears on their
website it helps maintain the quality
and integrity of your content finally
then we have content form 7. content
form 7 is a flexible and widely used
plugin for creating and managing contact
forms on your WordPress website it
allows you to customize form fields
define validation rules and set up email
notification with contact form 7 you can
create multiple forms manage form
submissions and integrate with other
plugins or Services then we have updraft
plus upgraph plus is a reliable backup
option that simplifies the processes of
backing up and restoring your WordPress
website it allows you to schedule
automatic backups and store them in
remote locations such as cloud storage
devices example Dropbox Google Drive
updraft enables you to selectively
restore specific components of your site
such as database or files in case of any
data loss or website issues male poet
mail poet is an email marketing and
newsletter plugin that enables you to
create send or manage new list
and manage newsletters directly from
your WordPress threshold it provides a
drag and drop email editor subscriber
management features automation
capabilities woocommerce integration
analytics and Reporting and gdpr
compliance tool then we have Elementor
Elementor is a popular page builder
plugin that enables you to create
visually appealing and responsive pages
without encoding knowledge it features a
drag and drop interface allowing you to
add and arrange various elements on your
page effortlessly Elementor offers a
wide range of pre-designed templates
widgets and styling options to help you
customize the appearance of your website
with ease then we have WP forms WP forms
is a beginner friendly plugin for
creating and managing forms on your
website it provides a drag and drop form
Builder interface making it easy to
create contact forms registration forms
surveys payment forms and more
WP forms offers a range of customization
options including form Fields
conditional logic email notification and
integration with popular email marketing
web services finally we have word
friends security Warframe security is a
comprehensive security plugin that
protects your website from threats and
vulnerabilities
it features a fireball to block
malicious traffic malware scanning to
identify and remove malicious code
login security measures to prevent
unauthorized access and real-time threat
defense to Monitor and block suspicious
activities
Vodafone security helps ensure the
safety and integrity of your website and
so these were the plugins that offers a
wide range of functionalities and can
significantly enhance your WordPress
website's SEO e-commerce capabilities
security performance and user experience
you can choose the plugins that best
suit your website's requirement on
objects
but before we wrap up let's discuss the
benefits and demerits of using Wordpress
WordPress it is a widely used content
management system that powers millions
of website worldwide so here are some
pros and cons of using Wordpress first
we have Pros
so first we have ease of use
WordPress has a user-friendly interface
and a simple setup process making it
accessible to beginners with little to
no technical expiratories then we have
customization options with WordPress you
can access thousands of themes and
plugins that allows you to customize the
design and functionality of your website
this flexibility enables you to create a
unique online presence then we have SEO
friendly WordPress provides various SEO
tools and plugins that can help optimize
your website for search engines it
offers features like customizable
permalinks meta tags XML sitemaps which
can improve your site's visibility in
search engine results
then we have scalability so whether you
are running a personal block or a large
e-commerce website WordPress can handle
websites of all sizes it is highly
scalable allowing you to expand your
site's functionality and accommodate
increasing traffic as your needs
involved then we
have First Security WordPress is a
popular content management system
making it a common Target for hackers
however you can mitigate this risk by
implementing security best practices
such as keeping your themes and plugins
up to date and using strong passwords
then we have maintenance and updates
regular maintenance is required to keep
your WordPress site running smoothly
this includes updating WordPress core
themes and plugins which can sometimes
result in compatibility issues or
require additional configuration then we
have plug-in dependency
WordPress offers a vast array of plugins
to extend your functionality however
relying on two heavily on plugins can
lead to Performance issues security
vulnerabilities and potential conflicts
between different plugins
then we have limited controls for hosted
websites if you choose to host your
WordPress site on wordpress.com or
another manage hosting platform you may
have limited control over server
configuration and back-end operations
this can restrict certain Advanced
customization options or make
troubleshooting more challenging
now it's important to note that while
WordPress has its drawback many of these
cons can be mitigated with proper
planning security measures and regular
maintenance ultimately the decision to
use WordPress depends on your specific
needs technical proficiency and
long-term goals of for your website and
that concludes our video on top 10
WordPress plugins we hope you found it
informative and discovered some useful
tools for your WordPress website so
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe to our channel for more
exciting content if you have any
questions or suggestions please leave
them in the comments box below thanks
for watching and we will see you in the
next video stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here